una coalición congelada codo con codo
pero sin mirarse la discordia entre
benjamin netanyahu y beni cant era
palpable en el parlamento con el
ministro de defensa dando la espalda al
primer ministro durante la votación del
primer paso para disolver el parlamento
y por lo tanto su acuerdo de reparto del
poder
benny ganz a favor benjamin netanyahu en
contra pero la disolución del parlamento
no es un hecho todavía se necesitan dos
votos adicionales dando a los políticos
israelíes tiempo para tratar de limar
sus diferencias la principal por el
momento es el presupuesto de israel para
2020 una vez en diciembre si el
presupuesto no está aprobado por el
parlamento es automáticamente disuelto
de todos modos cannes cuyo partido ha
caído en las encuestas podría perder su
reparto de poder establecido con una
nueva elección pero si la cuestión es
seguir adelante
más temprano podría ser mejor que tarde
dicen que netanyahu ha estado
obstaculizando el trabajo del gobierno y
está buscando una nueva elección a pesar
de su voto en contra una elección en la
primavera post kobe podría significar un
parlamento más amigable para netanyahu
uno que podría darle inmune
hacen un próximo juicio por corrupción
todos sabemos la verdad tú sabes la
verdad si no hubiera un juicio habría un
presupuesto si no hubiera un juicio
habría un gobierno que funcionaría
habría unidad
pero para netanyahu canses quien está
siendo difícil obviamente en momentos
dramáticos como estos no necesitamos ir
a las elecciones el pueblo de israel
quiere unidad no votaciones quiere
vacunas no anuncios de campañas grupos
directivos una compleja situación
política que significa que los israelíes
podrían volver a las urnas por cuarta
vez en menos de dos años